three two one mission sequence start and
liftoff the commercial space race is
reaching a critical point the private
American companies battling it out for a
3.5 billion dollar NASA contract have
one last chance to successfully launch
their spacecrafts before a decision is
made at the end of January each company
has been shuttling supplies to the
International Space Station to keep the
astronauts well-fed supplied and
occupied orbital ATK Elon Musk's space X
and Sierra Nevada Corporation are the
three contenders for the seven-year
contract forget NASCAR this race has
highest stakes and even bigger
explosions in October last year orbitals
Antares rocket blew up shortly after
liftoff
and this year masks Falcon 9 rocket also
exploded after launch from Canaveral a
big bang that costs taxpayers 110
million dollars still Congress wants
American companies to supply the ISS not
just Japan and Russia we've been raking
in millions of US dollars so the
pressure is on for each company to prove
it can make to the space station safely
orbitals next rocket lifts off December
third and SpaceX will launch there's a
month later fingers crossed